[Musique]
la pêche la chasse l'agriculture une
famille décide de vivre de la terre dans
le climat rigoureux du yukon le
documentaire first we did qui vise à
encourager la réflexion sur
l'autosuffisance alimentaire arrive à
point nommé
la première nord américaine aura lieu
jeudi sur internet c'est un des 150
documentaire diffusé en ligne
lors de la toute première édition
virtuelle du prestigieux festival hot
docs de toronto
le défi était immense
un peu comme créé de toutes pièces de
plateformes de diffusion à la netflix en
à peine six semaines
pas de longues files d'attentes cette
année donc place aux forfaits de style
vidéo sur demande un forfait de 5 films
coûtent 40 $ par exemple le moment est
opportun les documentaires et les plates
formes en ligne ont la cote plus que
jamais depuis le début de la pandémie au
dock songe déjà à une formule hybride en
ligne et en salle pour les prochaines
éditions
ce qui n'est pas une vilaine idée selon
ce journaliste cinématographique que les
gens apprécient tout coup sur les plates
formes qui vont même qui vont au moins
aller voir pour eux je pense que c'est
une solution extrêmement bien il ne
croit pas que la pandémie aura modifié à
long terme l'appétit pour le grand écran
même si les plateformes de diffusion
demeureront populaire il faudra
cependant que les cinéphiles se sentent
en sécurité lorsqu'ils iront en salle
soit que les salles de cinéma pourront
rouvrir je marche dure avec un nouvel
équilibre à trouver entre des salles de
cinéma et des plateformes
je pense que les cinéphiles qui voit
grand quand même hâte de retrouver la
fin de cinéma c'est ce que croit aussi
le directeur de la programmation des red
sox
aussi qu'il faudrait faire un effort
pour rencontrer dimanche pour l'instant
les précieux moments d'évasion et de
rêveries sont disponibles en ligne ici
philippe leblanc radio canada toronto